- LOOK AT ALL THESE
SHOTGUN SHELLS, MAN.
HE'S BEEN SLAMMING THEM LIKE
NO OTHER HUMAN I'VE EVER SEEN.
- EXCEPT FOR ME,
BUT TO YOUR POINT,
I'M NOT FULLY HUMAN.
MY UNCLE,
HE WAS A ZOOKEEPER.
- [shouting]
- THE DERS!
- [burping]
IT SHOULD BE MY NAME
ON THAT BANNER!
- WHOA, HEY.
SPIDERS, MAN.
WHY DON'T YOU SWOOP ON
DOWN HERE, BUDDY?
VERY SAFELY, THOUGH, PLEASE.
- YEAH, WHY DO YOU WORRY SO MUCH
ABOUT BANNERS, DUDE?
DRAKE'S NOT RAPPING
ABOUT BANNERS.
- YOU'RE REALLY INTO DRAKE, HUH?
- HE'S, LIKE, A REAL TALENT.
I JUST FOUND OUT ABOUT HIM,
AND HE RAPS ABOUT TROPHIES.
- [burping]
I COULD JUST PUT MY NAME
ON IT, RIGHT?
I'LL JUST PULL IT DOWN
AND CROSS OFF TORPEY'S NAME
AND MAKE EVERYTHING ALL RIGHT.
- IF YOU DO THAT,
YOU'RE GONNA DESTROY YOURSELF,
AND ACTUALLY, THAT'D BE
AWESOME TO WATCH, SO I VOTE YES.
- NO, ANDERS,
OKAY, IF YOU CAN HEAR ME,
IF YOU'RE EVEN IN THERE ANYMORE,
JUST COME DOWN, DUDE.
WE CAN FIX THIS.
- I AM FIXING THIS.
[shouting]
[all shouting indistinctly]
- I GOT IT!
[laughs]
OH, MY GOD!
- YES, THE DERS!
YEAH.
YES!
- THAT COULD HAVE GONE
WAY WORSE.
- DON'T LOOK DOWN.
- 'CAUSE YOU HAVE
AN ENTIRE TROPHY
STICKING OUT
OF YOUR FLUBBER.
- OH, MY GOD!
WHAT DO I DO?
- JUST RELAX, DUDE.
MY UNCLE BOBBY
ACTUALLY IMPALED HIMSELF
WITH A FIRE POKER
ONE CHRISTMAS.
HE HAD IT IN THERE
UNTIL NEW YEAR'S.
- OKAY, SO LEAVE IT IN.
- YEAH, HE'S FINE NOW.
- NO, NO, HE'S DEAD.
THEY FOUND HIM DEAD
NEW YEAR'S DAY,
'CAUSE OF THE FIRE POKER.